[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh come on man you could get
that buffed out no you can get that
buffed out
no knock and talk and talk
hands behind your head right now I got
this i'ma penetrate this man's soul with
my heart
what watch and learn sir I realize that
you scared you know sometime feel how
deep you think you got in his soul I'm
done my humble time oh oh here we go
again
he wants your legacy to be muscle shirts
and body counts do all this you didn't
shoot anybody
come on cab you know our shots yeah [ __ ]
me these streets I never trusted anybody
but you
I'm asking you man bad boys
one last time one last time I'm the
definition of we're not just black with
cops - we'll pull ourselves over later
right about the clock I've been telling
you I asked for here he can [ __ ] like
he's a like HD
bad boys bad boy
what she done it what you gonna do when
we come no never
y'all will never do that again yeah and
you [ __ ] up the lyrics which take a
long time and learn
[Music]